but when I started a Disney in 77 I tell
the story that where we got into the
training program we sat at the old
Disney desks and we had the scene
stackers and we had the tab or a beside
us we had the little clip to put the X
sheet on my back every the only thing in
my room that was not there and Snow
White was the electric pencil sharpener
so in 40 years literally nothing had
changed in the pipeline and so we
trained in the traditional way and I was
there for a couple years and I got the
films weren't exciting and then this guy
named Steve this burger came to
Hollywood and he came over to us and he
said I've got an idea for a new studio
and he and he paid the pitch to all of
us and I was the only one that bit and
left everybody else stay but I left and
I went to list burger studios I became
his animation director and I worked on
the future film called animal impacts
and then Steve had this idea for tron
this movie called Tron about a guy in a
computer and that was a exciting time
because at the time we really knew very
little about computers but we liked the
idea of doing a movie about computers
and Steve's dead people the minute the
word got out that Steve had this idea
people just started coming to the studio
yeah I remember Alan Kay is to fly down
from Xerox PARC and every weekend
consult with us the story sessions and I
used to have this thing on fridays i
would bring old animators and guys like
ken O'Connor down to talk to our crew
right and one friday i brought Walt
Peregoy down and thus you're laughing
because this is this very brilliant
designer he's most famous for the
hundred one Dalmatians look that
background styling but the guy was and
still to this day is like the worst
curmudgeon right he's a real salty dog
and he comes down to the studio to talk
to the crew right and everybody always
brings drawings or paintings and
original art walks in with nothing and I
get the whole crew into the conference
room and he gets up and he says you guys
have missed it and said we thought it's
over you know we did all the good stuff
you know it's done you guys you're gonna
have to do anything you know
and thank you for the motivational talk
while and I'll never forget the Steve
whisperer he looked them and he said
we're going to do stuff on that screen
that you cannot even imagine I remember
him saying that I got chills i would
still get chills thinking about that
moment and then of course we went on to
you know go to disney in and do Tron and
it was like every day was like christmas
morning you'd go in and there'd be some
new invention and we did this thing that
i ended up calling a you know symbiotic
filmmaking you know where with all these
technologists who knew nothing about
animation or art and of course we know
nothing about computers and so we would
work with them every day and say well
can you do this and I go well no we
can't do that but we can do this you
know
you